one of the best ways to start making
money online earning money from home
using the internet or adding an extra
stream of revenue to your current
business is affiliate marketing
affiliate marketing is simply a cool way
of earning a commission when you
recommend a product that you love or use
but how do you actually get started with
affiliate marketing and what are the
best tips for earning money quickly well
in this think marketing podcast you're
going to be learning five power tips in
exactly how to start coming up podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm shawn kennel
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or you
want to maximize video across all of
social media this podcast is for you I
am so fired up for today's episode
because it's all about how to get
started with affiliate marketing and
this topic has a very special place in
my heart because the way I was able to
go full-time working on my own terms
full-time freedom being able to work
from anywhere I want in the world work
on my own time on my own terms was using
YouTube and affiliate marketing and I'm
gonna be sharing in this video how I got
started some of the mistakes I made
early on and how you can overcome those
so you could start earning money faster
with affiliate marketing as well as some
power tips five specifically for how to
actually make sales and make money with
affiliate marketing now what you're
about to hear is actually a session that
I shared at my friend chalene johnson's
marketing impact Academy live event I
was in Orange County and I shared this
session it's actually a two-part podcast
and so in this episode you're gonna be
getting the first 5 tips and then stay
around for next week because we're gonna
be breaking down the next five tips and
chalene johnson is a huge friend and
mentor in my life and she's actually one
of our grow with video live speakers so
today's
Marketing podcast is brought to you by
our event which is a online experience
this year it's called grow with video
live you could check out all the details
that growth video live.com and among
many things in online business in
marketing in online video and really
specifically Instagram chalene johnson
is an incredible person and speaker and
she's one of our speakers this year at
grow with video live and of course
that's the event where we talk about all
things video how do you use video to get
more views followers grow your business
build a side project how do you master
LinkedIn YouTube Instagram all the
different platforms that have video how
do you grow with video that's the vision
of the conference and so we'll talk a
little bit more about that later
grow with video live.com but this
session get ready if you want to grab a
journal lean in there's some very
actionable and practical tips that yes
you can apply if you have a YouTube
channel and that's how you're sending
traffic but even if you're brand new to
this idea of affiliate marketing you're
going to love this session and if you're
more advanced you're probably gonna pick
up a few things that are gonna help you
earn more money with affiliate marketing
in your brand and business so buckle
your seatbelts gets ready get ready and
let's jump into the featured content
today on five tips to success with
affiliate marketing but I'm so excited
about this session because how many of
you would love to not have to sell your
own product but to be able to get
started really fast really easy and be
able to make a lot of money doing that
without having to create anything would
you want that awesome it's called
affiliate marketing and that's what
we're gonna be talking about today and
it's actually the way I got started
because it's the fastest way in shortest
what path to starting to make some
income online even if you're starting
from scratch and specifically we're
gonna break down how to earn a hundred
thousand plus a year with affiliate
marketing but this is relevant to
everybody in this room look the person
next to you and say it's relevant to you
boo
all of us can do affiliate marketing and
it's super relevant for our businesses
no matter where we're starting so let's
dive into it but hey my passion is
helping people build their influence
with online video you heard I wrote a
book called YouTube secrets and in this
session we're actually gonna be covering
how to get started with affiliate
marketing some pro strategies for
earning a hundred K a year the biggest
mistake I see people making or a few
mistakes with affiliate marketing as
well as a lot more I'm coming to you
from Las Vegas and I drove over here and
I live in Las Vegas with my beautiful
wife Sonya and our two chihuahuas Sophie
and Rosie and we have been married for
13 years yeah yeah no thanks I I guess
one of those things and I might look
young and I am and we got married when
we were 15 arranged marriages it's a
true we got married at 21 and I actually
met her at Starbucks and that was kind
of when my coffee addiction began you
know cuz I just started going in like a
multiple times a day you're back and I'm
like jittery
she's like I'm just looking for more
coffee you know and a true story like
when I went in I saw her I started
trying to find out what she likes that
started trying to kind of get her
attention I'm doing you know research
and I found out that she was in the
running and I wasn't into any athletics
at the time but once I got this
information I started getting some ideas
kind of like you're getting ideas at Mi
a any single people in the room come on
wait you're allowed to wave your hand hi
because I might be able to make some
connections Hey look around tonight
tomorrow at the dance okay but so I
started getting some ideas you know and
and and I was like what if I got some
running clothes just kind of threw them
on you know tattered them up a little
bit you know and then I just kind of
walked in one day and I just came in it
and it came with a guy yeah I'll just
get some coffee and she goes oh wait
you're into running clearly right
she goes maybe we should go running
together sometime and really the rest is
history that was our first date and like
I couldn't run very long either during
that first day dia they're just rotten
for a while and then watch but anyways
my beautiful wife Sonya and you know we
mentioned a bunch of stats and all this
different stuff but you know that one of
the the main traffic source for me has
been using online video specifically
YouTube but I want to encourage you you
know start before you're ready because
there's all of this I'm up here on stage
now and I've got a level of confidence
I've been putting these videos out the
stats of millions of views is really
staggering to me I'm a small town kid
from a city called Arlington Washington
an hour north of Seattle and so to be
hitting like numbers and all that stuff
seems absolutely crazy
but you all we all have to start
somewhere right you have to start before
you're ready so I thought just to kind
of set the atmosphere can I play one of
my early YouTube videos for you is that
okay I was gonna play this video so you
see this is the first video I uploaded
on my Sean I just can't old channel and
let's just see what it's like alright so
this is I guess the first Sean thinks
vlog and I'm gonna try to vlog every
single day mainly so I can remember what
I'm even doing and what's going on
because I just feel like I have a lot
and I'm thinking about and I figured hey
why not share it and if you find
something interesting that's awesome now
this is definitely as real as it gets
so I'm not going to try to be energetic
or entertaining though maybe sometimes I
will but anyways
come on yeah
I tell you what man you got to start
before you're ready and we like to say
you got a punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face and press
record and I'm so thankful that I did
because since that time we've just been
able to see massive impact now we've got
a team of about 10 people in Las Vegas
and we're running a media company our
main channels called think media and so
we do a lot of content they're also
running a channel with the co-founder my
friend Benji called video influencers
and two channels to check out online
Forbes listed us came out with the book
YouTube secrets you heard about that but
I'll never forget 2009 though like in
the journey of where I am today it's a
year that was absolutely insane and I
look back and I really get emotional
because we hit the hardest season of our
lives for my wife and I and at the time
we were living in Seattle and things
just began to hit us from every side the
first thing that happened was my wife
went on a trip and she got very ill and
we didn't know what was happening and so
we were visiting doctors and and and she
was being mixed diagnosed and losing all
of this weight and eventually dropped
down to 82 pounds and she almost died
and I actually found myself in the
hospital room by her side for six days
just praying and was wondering what our
future held and just being challenged
like what is what are we gonna do and
where are we gonna go and if that wasn't
enough it was also right during during
the housing crisis and and here in
America you probably remember 2007 89
and just the market crashing and we had
we were both working jobs and we bought
a house we had a rental property and and
though if this thing started to fall
apart so our finances are just getting
devastated and my background getting
into video in the first place was
actually working at a church and I was
doing video production there and then
some things started to follow up a some
people stole some money so the church
started to fall apart and you would
trusted leadership and and so like as if
everything I could fall around fall
apart around us it was all happening at
once so we were just getting crushed
from every side we're losing money we're
losing jobs and it puts you into a
situation where you're thinking why like
why god
is happening what are we gonna do but
you're also thinking what like what what
am I gonna do next
and I felt challenged as a leader as a
man to really step up and I started to
look for answers and look for solutions
at a major level and I think that I
learned two big lessons during this that
maybe applies to you because right now
you could be just killing it and your
business things are going great but
maybe you're in a situation where
whether it's business or family or life
or health where you actually can relate
at a major level maybe you're
experiencing some major pain and just
some some intense a season like this and
two lessons I learned from really going
through hell was number one I love this
quote if you're going through hell keep
going like don't stop like that's not
the time to pitch a tent and just start
camping right you got to keep moving and
that was really the first lesson was
keep moving forward keep progressing
keep keep just advancing doing whatever
you can to put one step one foot in
front of the other but the second lesson
was you got to keep learning and I love
that you're here because there is a way
out of whatever situation you have that
you're in right now there is a solution
to the problem if someone on planet
Earth found a way to get over that
chronic illness or that situation with
children or with maybe some learning
disability or something or someone got
through that obstacle you're facing in
your business which the human race is
amazing for overcoming obstacles than
you can - then you can - especially if
you keep learning and I learned that
every obstacle can actually become an
opportunity because it was during that
season that I discovered two things that
changed my life
the first one was the power of YouTube
but for today's conversation I want us
to just think of it as traffic and when
I say traffic I just mean views like a
way to get attention to your content
Rachel this crushed it talking about
Facebook that's a way to get traffic
look at your neighbor and say traffic
yeah
traffic so YouTube for me was the way I
started to figure out how to actually
get like views get awareness get things
going on but the second was affiliate
marketing and affiliate marketing
changed my life and once I started to
figure it out what we're gonna dive into
today I started to discover
some incredibly powerful things so
here's a case study it's the older video
you can see it's like six years old so I
started to do these weird experiments
and this video was called gift ideas for
him so I just sat down on my couch and I
just went around the house because I
figured out what affiliate marketing was
gathered up some things I owned I figure
I'm a him and I like stuff let me talk
about some gift ideas for a him in your
life you know what I mean and so I put
the video out and then in the
description of that YouTube video
there's links and that link is an
affiliate link and then also here in the
scene you can see on the screen Apple
head Chihuahua named Rosie no point
there I just really love her I thought
she deserved a blue arrow she might help
you drive more sales though dogs and
kids right but anyways so we put that in
that link in the description and I'll
never forget this this is that back in
2010 my first affiliate payment ever I
started dabbling in this you're not
gonna believe it and I and I put some
content out there and how it's like man
this is a magic pill oh man this thing
works
and sure enough I made two dollars and
12 cents thank you everybody have a good
night so so like but but I love this
because it really is tells us this
lesson of don't despise small beginnings
and once you've made that first dollar
online your next question is then cool
how do i scale that like if I can make a
dollar then I just need to figure out
how to do that more and more and more
and repeat the process and refine the
process and I can make a bigger impact
and so I just grabbed a screenshot of
our amazon associates account so this is
the Amazon affiliate program January
2019 we did sixteen thousand three
hundred and seventy four dollars so when
we add that up from around Amazon we're
gonna do around two hundred thousand
dollars in profit this year it's pretty
cool there's another affiliate program
this is a few years worth but it's
generated around forty three thousand
three hundred and forty-one dollars in a
matter of years through not owning a
product myself for just being really a
middleman just standing in between the
conversation of someone that's looking
for a solution and me introducing that
solution to them super cool this is
another affiliate program put
a few videos out there it's generating
$15 a day true passive income on
autopilot and so really quick who here
you actually are unsure what affiliate
marketing is and raise your hand as high
as you can don't lie you're nothing to
be embarrassed about
okay if we're really quick I wanna make
sure this is good so a few people in the
know me the first time you're hearing
about this here's what affiliate
marketing is it's basically when you
review or recommend a product online and
you earn a commission when someone
purchases it here's my definition it's a
cool way to make money sharing the
products you love and that you actually
use so here's how it works if you go to
Amazon's affiliate site it's called
Amazon Associates you can just tap that
type that in Google you can then sign up
and so you can even select different
countries and whatnot to be a part of
different programs we would typically
probably sign up here for the US Amazon
affiliate program so you select that you
sign up and then once you do it you sign
up and this would be true for any
affiliate program you just find the
website sign up then what it gives you
the ability to do is create trackable
links those links are now your
personalized links so whether it's on a
blog or in the show notes of your
podcast or in a description of a youtube
video then you can now put that link
there so if someone goes through it
that's how that brand like Amazon knows
how to attribute any sales that happen
to you so in a youtube sense I would put
that link in my youtube description you
could again use it on a blog anywhere
else that you want some visitors will
end up clicking that link and then if
they make a purchase you make money
super cool right so that's how affiliate
marketing works and so today I just want
to talk about ten affiliate marketing
Pro tips and we'll weave through out
here whether you're just getting started
you'll get a lot out of this but even if
you're more advanced in this room
there's definitely gonna be some nuggets
that I think you'll love so tip number
one is simply share products you're
passionate about share products you're
passionate about for me I started video
production back in 2003 because I was
volunteering at my local church and I
started to get into cameras and gear and
I started to find out that I was
passionate about it but I started to
love tech and so I put videos out
helping people with cameras I started
you know around 2010 doing this and this
is an old older video actually the
screenshot super old now but like I just
start talking about cameras but this
video was two million views and so as
people watched it then they would click
the link in the description to buy
cameras and that's how we scale to some
of this income something I was just
passionate about it just came
organically from my world my friend
Nikki Phillippi she's also a youtuber
social-media influencer and so she makes
videos like cozy winter night pamper
routine I'm gonna do my pamper routine
next month but I need to catch up too
and so she does that video and so she
goes through and to her tribe to her
community she's adding value she's
adding some entertainment but she talks
about a few different products in that
video right and so then in the
description of her YouTube video there's
a list of my bathtub her actual bathtub
and that is her bathtub but you can buy
the whole bathtub
twinkle lights the candles the epson
salt a hydro flask tan luxe face cheese
skin infusion mmm like you know a lot of
cool stuff and so this is an example of
just stuff you love stuff you use stuff
you could educate your tribe about cool
stuff you want to pass along how many
you guys recognize this guy
[Applause]
what a savage you know should you eat
kale no hi skinny I like you sort it and
and ironically but but I was asking that
Brett was telling me about just one
affiliate program that he's a part of
and it's called butcher box right and so
I'm sorry vegans and if so I did so he
put this out and and oh the over there
generating six figures a year just from
butcher box and there's a couple
distinctions about affiliate programs
like this that are powerful is some -
some of them have continuity so if
someone signs up one time to a
subscription every single month that
that subscription renews for that
individual you're earning a percentage
on that sale so it's super cool because
you do it once but then that becomes
stacking passive income and the way he
was driving traffic is through emails
did you already have an email list maybe
you sent out a value email teach some
stuff a few links and also just calls to
action on Instagram and stories in the
feed and in stories as well and so
whenever you're looking for an affiliate
program you could look for this the way
you search you could write this down
here's the formula type in brand name
you're interested in + affiliate program
or Ambassador Program or partner program
or referral program you've got to get
the idea but if you type in like the
brand name and that word like affiliates
that's what I did I just typed in
butcher box affiliate and it brought me
to this page and then it actually shows
me that it's a part of an affiliate
network now we kind of get into some
tactics but what you would do is you try
to sign up for a share a sale or an
affiliate Network like flex offers and
what they are is they're like a network
once you get approved that then there's
multiple brands underneath it so if you
wanted to sign up for butcher box you go
to share a sale get your account set up
and then look and here it says you'll
get a commission ten to twenty dollars
per subscription and it also says a
cookie
didn't mean that to be a joke it's
actually it's a Mattel's you the cookie
duration this is like information you
need to know what a cookie is it's kind
of when Rachel was like make sure you
have your pixel installed and after room
is like what is a pixel what is going on
at marketing impact Academy's words I am
hungry I would like a cookie it's too
come on okay and so the cookie is simply
a tracking cookie is what it means but
it says 30 days so check it out if
someone clicks your link one time then
for 30 days if they make a purchase on
butcher box it'll remember that you sent
them there and you'll get the Commission
amazon's cookie is 24 hours which is not
too bad because they sell so much
different stuff you get credit even if
they buy stuff you didn't recommend and
so different cookie lengths that's a
little affiliate marketing information
and let's keep going so that's tip
number one share stuff you're passionate
about share stuff that you love tip
number two brand alignment brand
alignment I love what Selena's been
sharing all day about figuring out your
brand like figuring out your message
what Rachel there's talking to the QA
like like you can't be about everything
but when you stay in brand alignment it
makes sense to recommend products that
are adjacent to maybe your core offer
and there's so many for you like again
you you if you're talking about fitness
and actual workout stuff you know me
this guy you could clearly you can see
I've been working out okay come on coach
Jimmy I need some help on these guns
here I run too much these things get
thinner every day okay brand alignment
brand alignment so for instance on my
channel I talk about cameras that's
obvious I talk about computers
it's the tools for creators like what's
the kind of gear you need to create
video content great photos and so in
this example on screen I review a
computer I talk about it I talk about a
camera I talk about a tripod but then
even over here I talk about a standing
desk because we're number one it's
electronic but number two the promise of
my channel think media my tagline is the
best tips and tools for helping you
build your influence with online video
and so the promise is I'm I'm going to
the strategies to learn video and make
money online and I'm also going to give
you the tools and so we talked about it
ties into my channel maybe not the best
but I want to make sure things are
aligned so it's like yeah it's keep your
energy high you if you sit all day
editing or working on your business
standing desks whatever it is but brand
alignment now gives you the opportunity
to tie in affiliate offers that could be
additional income revenue streams for
you and your channel so on my Sean
candle channel just my personal brand I
did a video best self-improvement books
and great video obviously the links are
affiliate links in the description below
but this isn't go on my think media
channel because that would definitely be
off-brand like that would be operon so I
think it's important that you might see
some ways to make money with affiliate
marketing but you may or may not you
want to make sure it's on brand this is
Heather and she's actually part of the
think media team she's our chief
operation officer but she's also got a
great YouTube channel for homeschool mom
some people researching homeschool and
so normally she's given a lot of advice
a lot of encouragement but she can turn
on an affiliate stream of income by
recommending some books like three books
for homeschool moms and every month
she's now getting like $150 Amazon gift
cards on a little side project of her
YouTube channel of passive income coming
in for her and her family super super
cool tip number three is bolt-on passive
income look at your neighbor and say
bolt-on super weird like what does that
even mean okay here's what I mean by
Bolton is a good example I just bought
my wife Sonya a Jeep there you and and
so it was it was one it was like a dream
car and we were just recently able to
take it up into the snow and and when I
think about a Jeep at first I wasn't
even one of those Jeep guys I thought
jeeps did stay it stood for just empty
every pocket I was raised I don't know
why I heard that but and I wasn't that
into it but once she she she's like no I
really want this Jeep jeeps are awesome
so we took it out we were like driving
in the snow she's like you want to drive
I'm like okay cool and then I started
like whipping you know just around we're
just driving over stuff
you know super fun and so we got this
Jeep but when you have a jeep or any
kind of car when I think of bolt on you
can bolt on a lot of cool things to the
Jeep so now I'm getting pumped I'm like
okay we're getting a winch we're gonna
get one of those dope red you know car
guy here look how masculine I am one of
those ready thing flippy things in the
car
awesome and so going to get like a winch
get some fog lights get you know this
the red thing and and these are things
you can bolt on to your your Jeep which
can already get you from point A to
point B what's exciting about affiliate
marketing is there's a lot of ways to
bolt on additional income streams you
already have a core business but there's
other things that you could do and so
ask yourself what affiliate marketing
offers can you add to your current
business so going back to my friend
Nikki Phillippi
she actually does Young Living and and
does is selling essential oils and has
her network marketing business going but
then she also has those affiliate
marketing links as well so I hope that
whatever it is you're doing you're doing
both because in that video she's doing
her essential oils unboxing she's
talking about some things but in the
description of that same content she's
also recommending whether that's the
diffuser or other things she would
recommend you can bolt on additional
income streams even if it's not your
core business and a lot of times they
can be very passive you've seen chalene
do this she's got she leans favorite
things on her website here's the to-do
list or an action item write down that
you should put on your website or
whatever you live online like a list of
just the things you use in your business
like it's really smart too because once
you've built your business you can put a
page up and you could say I use kajabi
two-horse might host my courses that's a
referral link you could say I'm using
get response or Aweber or something for
email that could be your affiliate link
you might say my favorite camera happens
to be the canon a DD that's an affiliate
link on your favorite things list and so
she's got the slide board right up top
and then you can you click that link it
takes you over to
Amazon and that's her affiliate link
once it's built once it's sitting there
it's just a bolt-on income stream and
then someday when you want to just send
a tweet you might be you know what am I
gonna do to my business hey if you guys
are ever curious about what my favorite
things are tweet but the page is already
done like if you in an email in a PS you
could just say and by the way or
whatever it is or let's say you're doing
a launch and you offer some things and
people who don't buy with you or they
don't buy your digital product that you
put out there you could follow up and
say here's a bunch of other cool stuff
that I just want to add is free value
but those are your affiliate links right
super cool another thing that's cool
right now is Amazon is expanded into the
influencer program and so you can apply
to get your custom page on Amazon so you
could screenshot that link if you want I
reckon I highly recommend this because
there's a lot of authority to it even if
you don't get approved for this now
because that it is a little bit of an
application process they just want to
see that you have some influence but
definitely something to aspire to and
what you get signed up for that you
could create a custom page like I'm
living on amazon.com you could see some
of my tech recommendations and you can
also see that I did not update my cover
image and this morning as I was
listening to chalene and feeling super
guilty and overwhelmed by everything I
haven't done in my business and then as
I was going through these slides I just
wanted to give up
is that okay can I be real all right so
but I share that though because even me
I'm like oh man there's stuff I gotta
fix stuff I got to do remember we got to
pace ourselves so this is really cool
and so originally this was not a very
good page meaning the program but now
you can make categories so they kind of
give you a dynamic website that you can
create through the influencer program so
again in an instant now you can just
send people right to your affiliate page
where you can generate additional
revenue in your business super super
cool number four hey I hope you're
getting value out of this video so far
and if you are can you smash the like
button all right let's get right back
into it
number four timing is everything timing
is everything we're talking about 10
different pro tips for making more money
in your business or starting to make
money with affiliate marketing this gift
ideas video that I mentioned is actually
super relevant imagine though what time
of year do you think this would be the
most relevant naturally right and so
what's cool here is that this video is
really old but if you look at the
traffic on it on YouTube every year
there is like this spike in viewership
right around that particular time of
year this also lends itself to saying
that is when you should put out
you should put out strategic content at
strategic times so you might show up for
your audience just to say hey it's it's
it's summer here's a few recommendations
for summer right that's timing it's
around the holidays there's some gift
ideas for people in your life whatever
that is so every year around Black
Friday especially in Cyber Monday as a
tech guy I always do like the best Black
Friday deals the best cyber monday deals
because of the timing around that gift
ideas theme Omar who is on the thick
media team did a video on his channel
called gift ideas for photographers just
something that could serve his tribe he
knows who he's serving as this
world-class photographer and then you
could see his video there with his gift
idea so now he's just got some passive
income and a key term here regarding
timing is tentpoles industry term
tentpoles
what is a tentpole well a tentpole is a
something like this on Google Trends
which is a great website you
go to Google Trends type in a term like
Black Friday or type in a term maybe
even like a conference that you go to
that maybe gets a lot of traffic
depending on the company you're a part
of or your team or whatever it is it
could be anything and it'll then showed
you when interest in that particular
term spikes and that's why it's called a
tenth if you look at it it's you can you
can live under their code it's you you
just set your tent up you go camping oh
wow it's amazing but that's why it's
called a tent pole and so then you can
see it kind of goes up then it spikes up
and you'd want to catch it not too early
but you want to catch it right at the
beginning of that rise so what I
actually learned about Black Friday is
that November 12 through the 18th is
when a massive rise in search in
popularity starts so us shoppers spent 5
billion dollars that was back in 2017
and so when I position my content at a
strategic time right and you put it out
right at that smart time you have the
best chance of just getting sucked up
into the psychology of what everybody's
looking for right and and so that would
be a tent pole and that's all related to
timing for your and there's a little
uptick if so if you see there right I
wouldn't do it before that little ramp
but I want my video to basically come
out on November 12th and then I want
that to ride all the way through that
particular holiday in this case and so
ask yourself like what are the tent
poles in your industry this could be
things like summer new years new year
new you boo we're back it could be like
a time to rest like maybe there's a time
when you actually realize for your
audience you the conversation you need
to be having is more like it's time to
take some type off here's some vacation
ideas here's some pampering ideas for
you
like write and take some time to write
this down what holidays are super
relevant to your business and brand or
what events like even around conferences
we cover event called CES every year
Consumer Electronics Show and there
might be a conference that you could
even get kind of some traffic off of or
some awareness off of how to survive or
whatever it is these are 10
there's things that will trend in in
their popularity and then they drop but
they potentially do it year after year
after year after year could be the
Superbowl whatever it is tie your
content and your strategies into those
things so you can get more views
awareness and traffic and so a power tip
is calendar block the planning and
preparation time for your strategic
promotions right and that's that's maybe
obvious but like look ahead so you have
the time to block on your calendar okay
this would be a great time to just make
sure I get this video shot or this blog
post written or this podcast recorded so
that I can release it at that opportune
time to capitalize on that trend and
that timing tip number five maximize
trends maximize trends so as marketers
you're in the job of spartax spotting
trends especially for your industry you
want to keep your your thumb on the
pulse you want to be paying attention to
the trends in your industry and so this
is even my industry but I'm just kind of
a trends guy and on my personal channel
I do a lot of experiments so these are
laser Christmas lights they're LED laser
Christmas lights that you plug into your
yard and they shoot little dots of light
onto your house or they shoot these
Christmas trees onto your house and if
we're honest they look horrible right I
mean these things they're like like
there is no self-respecting male who's
leading his family well would use these
I use these though actually like these
are and I'll tell you why because I get
it I and some guys in the room they're
like no I am Clark Griswold
I am National Lampoon's Christmas I will
have the best house in the neighborhood
I'll be up on the roof doosh doosh doosh
I'm gonna do the lights I'm gonna blow
breakers not me friend
these may be ugly but I'll tell you how
long they take to set up five minutes is
me trying to find the extension cord in
my garage it would only be 20 seconds I
just don't know where the extension cord
is
that's the first five minutes the second
five minutes is then going out into my
rocky front yard in Vegas whose we now
have grass we have astroturf in our back
yard and like banging this thing into
the ground and plenty of the house
plugging it in and then it's done so
it's about a ten minute project to get
my Christmas lights done are we proud of
them no there's my wife respect me no
but
what you'll learn here is that I was
that you need to spot and look for
trends and so as I started seeing these
lights coming out this is when it hit me
it was when I walked into my local
grocery store it's called a Smith's and
I walked in and I'm just there for the
usual kale and avocado and and whatever
and and I'm going through and I saw a
full display of these for sale in a
grocery store and I was like man these
things are these things are here now
like just like me all the lazy people
and all the you know the these are gonna
be hot so then I just went home and I
did some keyword research I was like
okay who online like is there anybody
looking for laser Christmas LED lights
and sure enough there was like thousands
of searches a month you can use like
Google Google Keyword planner for that
in fact let me give you a tool write
this down key words everywhere com oh my
gosh I love this thing's totally free
keywords everywhere com install it into
your browser it's gonna tell you the
search volume just right on the page on
Google on Amazon it'll like when you
start typing the Amazon it'll tell you
how much search on YouTube it just gives
you the number nice and easy so I go
home and I discover okay these are a hot
trend and so what I did was I put a
video in front of them best Christmas
laser lights and I just talked about
these things and in that first year I
generated four thousand dollars in
profits from just the lights themselves
now what's crazy is that every single
year after I'm still the dominant voice
because no other male is willing to step
out there
no shame in my game bro and now my wife
respects me because I bought her a jeep
let's go
[Applause]
right and so but no here's what's crazy
is remember I was talking about cookies
like when you put out content around the
holidays when someone's shopping for
this they click your link it tracks for
24 hours well you know what people are
doing they're not just looking for
lights they're buying Christmas gifts or
buying stuff for other people so I've
learned that the profit we make about
50% of the stuff we sell as stuff I've
never even recommended or talked about I
remember the golden coin I sold once I
woke up in the morning I sold a $1,500
gold coin
Hey I didn't know Amazon sold gold coins
B I didn't know Amazon sold gold coins
but see I made one hundred and eighty
seven dollar Commission while I was
asleep because someone just clicked that
link and made another purchase so the
strategic time we're talking about
trends this was a trending item I saw
the trend I put some content in front of
it and then absolutely crushed it with
sales and then year after year it
continues to generate and sell even
other stuff so a super cool thing what
are the trends in your industry that you
can maximize affiliate marketing is so
powerful and that was just part one of
10 tips for not just getting started
with affiliate marketing but earning
more money with affiliate marketing
whether you're using YouTube I highly
recommend it but look affiliate
marketing works for blogging podcasting
really any channel and there's so many
different ways to apply it and I want to
remind you today's episode is brought to
you by our conference grow with video
live in fact if you want to learn more
about how do you get views how do you
actually get traffic because the key to
earning money with affiliate marketing
is actually getting buttes like a key to
get you know to actually get people to
buy some products or actually get enough
traffic to reach those income targets
and those income goals that you have is
how do you grow with video and so if you
haven't got your tickets yet go to
growth video live.com grow a video live
is a powerful conference because we
really focus on three things
there's the strategy the psychology in
the community and what I've learned is
that a lot of other people in our
industry are not hitting all three
here's what I mean the strategy side is
the tips and the tactics and the
practical mechanics of succeeding with
online video and growing and online
business very important
critical however I've learned that the
strategy is not enough you also need the
right mindset beliefs you need the right
psychology so we also focus on that
there I think maybe if you've been a
part of the think marketing community
for a while you've noticed that we focus
a lot on that motivation speaking to
your heart you've connected with Heather
tourists and heard man she brings so
much boldness and passion and really
helps us get over our BS if you want to
succeed on YouTube you got to get over
to your BS Shawn what are you talking
about your belief system right that's
what should be s is you got a re rewire
your belief system so that you can take
massive action on the strategies that
you have but the third piece is
community it's not just about strategy
it's not just about psychology it's also
about community connecting with other
Purpose Driven entrepreneurs
purpose-driven creators and growth video
live 2020 is a virtual conference it's
in a virtual experience this year for
the safety of our speaker safety of our
community and just the practicality of
what's kind of happening in the world
right now we're going online but that
doesn't mean it's gonna be low on
community we're gonna be doing some very
special and intentional things for
having a highly interactive community
building activities where we're gonna be
doing interactive things this is not
just like a one-way stream like was it
just like a livestream of the content no
it's gonna be absolutely amazing so
you're not gonna want to miss it and you
can get a ticket to grow a video live
starting at as low as just $97 so growth
video live.com you can see all of our
speakers come on Pat Flynn Pete Vargas
chalene johnson man we got Katherine
content bugs Stephanie Lu who's been on
a think marketing podcast Chris Ducker
talking about personal branding all
kinds of stuff so go to go video
live.com of course you can check out
links in the description or the show
notes wherever you're watching or
listening to this and I do want to also
pass off of course the question of the
day to you which made us be for your
journal which just maybe for your notes
which just made for you be for you to
answer if you're listening to this on
the audio version but if you can drop a
comment because you're watching the
video podcast the question of the day is
what is one product that you could
promote as
and affiliate what is a product that's
relevant to you and your business
you know you might do affiliate
marketing as your main source of income
originally affiliate marketing was more
important to me than YouTube ads because
YouTube ads with a smaller audience
aren't gonna fully pay your mortgage but
affiliate marketing did for me
fast like it took time to build but it
was way more in affiliate marketing it's
probably earning about five thousand a
month when I went full-time on YouTube
with the Filioque marketing and only
eight hundred a month with YouTube ads
if I was just doing YouTube ads one of
the been enough and so affiliate
marketing was the game-changer for me
but look you might already have a
business why can't you talk about the
software that you use in your business
or talk about some of the top five
products in your niche and send an email
to your current customers of hey here's
a couple other things that are related
an adjacent topic to you know what you
talk about and your branding your
business and they might be like this is
so awesome and they buy some stuff and
you earn a commission there's so many
different affiliate programs there's so
many different ways to do it I'm passing
the question off to you what is one
product you could promote as an
affiliate that ties into your brand your
niche and your industry and that brings
us to the comet of the day on the think
marketing podcast and today's comet is
from LP Oh David Guru's of content and
something else that's dot dot dot these
guys are the top of their game this
podcast is offering valuable information
on video content production in multiple
aspects and also in all related fields
to secondarily apply to it great show
well hey thank you so much for the kind
words if you have been enjoying the
think marketing podcast please rate and
review the podcast on Apple iTunes you
know maybe you normally watch this on
YouTube on the video podcast maybe
listen on Spotify and wherever you
listen to it thank you so much for being
a part of the community but it would
mean the world to myself
Heather tourists and the think media
team if you left us a rating and review
on Apple iTunes or Apple podcasts and
thanks for that great
view look I hope that you're always
hanging around till the end of the think
marketing podcast because this is where
the rubber meets the road and what is
that
it's the hashtag action takers it's the
time where we don't just get some
information but know we put it into
action it's not just about information
it's about implementation right now it's
time to take action what is your next
step is it to focus on traffic first
growing your YouTube channel getting
views growing your audience getting
started creating content you know
influence comes first income comes
second or is it about putting the right
videos out or talking about the right
affiliate product and really get ready
for part two because we're gonna be
talking about some advanced tips that
layer on these first five that'll help
you get even more revenue get more
creative ideas for how you can earn
money with affiliate marketing affiliate
marketing is just one of the many ways
to make money online in the new economy
and make sure you stick around like
comment share this with somebody that
needs to hear it but let's put this into
action and I can't wait to see you and
hear you or you hear me okay something
like that on the next week of the think
marketing podcast appreciates you so
much hashtag action takers go take
action this week and put some of this
stuff into practice and we will hear you
see you connect with you in the next
episode peace